hey we'll be on with your regular
programming and Nick depalo in third
chair in a little bit uh but needed to
take a moment here to address some
issues out there uh that are circulating
uh it's never fun but um
well I guess let me be clear here uh I
have been living with a proverbial boot
on my neck for going on years now
uh since 2021 I've been living through
what has increasingly been a horrendous
divorce now let me say on the outset to
be clear there is no infidelity any kind
of physical abuse at all on either side
and no this was not
my choice my then wife decided that she
didn't want to be married anymore
and in the state of Texas that is
completely permitted
it's been the most heartbreaking
experience of my life what I consider to
be my deepest personal failure and just
so you know my opinions on parenting and
families have not changed I've always
believed that children need a mom and a
dad that divorce is horrible
and I still believe that children need a
mom and a dad and that divorce is
horrible
but in today's legal system
my beliefs don't matter
in Texas divorces permitted when one
party wants it
period
so for well over a year uh well over a
year in the best interest as well as
physical safety of my children we've
decided to keep this issue private and
to resolve it uh privately with the
appropriate attorneys what have you
legal jargon and all this one thing I
want to be really clear about is certain
True North here is that
my children are blameless
completely without fault and so we
decided to resolve these issues
privately as it's in their best
interests both emotionally and
physically to do so
now the other issue is
and this is something that I've kept
private
for likely far too long
um
many other people knew about this
behind the scenes
some not all but some of them in
positions of power
influence
Leverage
new of this
they also knew that the safety of my
children included keeping it private so
if you're familiar with the idea of
extortion
then you know the feeling well
uh now some of these
threats
were so thinly veiled that I'm frankly
surprised you didn't all guess
immediately
Stephen has a lot going on
I guess is the best way to say it he has
a lot going on and that should be clear
because people don't do stuff like this
if there's not a lot going on in their
lives I would like to implore my
audience and everybody that isn't paying
attention to this situation not to
condemn him but to pray for him
sometimes people need a prayer sometimes
people need a scripture you know Stephen
purports to be a Christian I am unsure
at this moment if it is my place to say
more than that you know maybe if I feel
in further defense something should be
said or maybe if I feel that the public
has a right to understand certain
circumstances
all my children have a right to privacy
now some other issues have been or I
should say uh
inferences have been more pernicious
behind the scenes with demands and
threats to use this information that
they believe would be so publicly
embarrassing to me and my wife in a
difficult time that it could be used
knowingly putting my children In Harm's
Way so to those self-styled Christians
conservatives and allies
well not in my book
now if you find yourself I don't want to
get into details so this is going to
likely be the only time I have to
address this or want to address this if
you're asking yourself hey did X person
or did y person know the answer is
likely yes
which will be made alarmingly clear as
this process of discovery continues uh
and it also by the way makes me that
much more appreciative of those who did
know about this and in understanding the
best interests of my family my children
kept their word and used discretion
I can't thank you enough sincerely I
appreciate it won't forget it it's it's
pretty simple I
loved a woman so much that I married her
a woman who despite all of this I still
love as the mother of my children
and she wanted something else for her
life
that's not my choice
she simply wanted out and the law says
that that's how it works now of course
look I get it there are multiple sides
to every story but one thing that is
undeniable uh in this case that it's no
one's fault but my own
in that I picked wrong and that's
certainly not the fault of my children
and I will say that what's in the best
interest of my children is not internet
drama speculation
certainly not blatant or veiled
shakedowns or dragging their father or
mother and I can't be clear on enough or
their mother through the mud
and to anyone who tries it
I'm no longer going to pacify capitulate
or sidestep because I love them a whole
lot more than I love you and I will
continue to do whatever is necessary to
protect my children
discussing a divorce any further on
social media or on this show or in any
public space it's not what's best for
them
I'll be handling this through the proper
legal Avenues and channels available as
a matter of record in which I have more
than full confidence
so I'd ask that you understand the need
for and respect our privacy and
what is obviously a pretty tough time
and I hope that none of this has to go
any further than that now on with the
reason you're all actually here
[Music]
you're streaming down
oh I'm in a space Steve Crowder is
a gross person I mean Stephen Crowder I
mean this is what you can expect from
trash like YouTube dragged his feet
before taking any action against
conservative commentators Stephen
Crowder who is that Stephen Crowder
Stephen Crowder is YouTube's ideal
Creator he makes cheap long content that
tons of people watch and subscribers
voices are really funny so congrats on
that you know what you can do with your
copyright strikes
and if you ain't man enough to do it
yourself
I'd be happy to oblige
[Music]
I really would going on there
all kind of things but I don't mind
from where I am the sun is shining here
to entertain
can't get bomb
now
tonight
[Music]
thank you Stephen Crowder
from where I am the sun is shining here
to entertain
Ed thank you
[Music]
if you is Stephen Crowder
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
did I I just saw you look down is it
what oh no I was trying to block that
horrible sucking of your coffee oh okay
I think we'll do away with it we can
take a vote on it and by the way I think
the view counter is working at Rumble
yesterday crashed again so we'll talk
about that today a lot to get to Biden
former Vice President Biden reannounced
his reannouncing of his re-election the
point is no one cares but we'll talk
about it because he delivered a commie
speech in which everything is verifiably
false you're seeing Don Lemon out
yesterday we actually funny enough
scooped CNN we did accidentally that
Tucker is out and I will tell you this
it's not just about Tucker Carlson you
know you see the horrible attacks that
that took place on Matt Walsh you see
Dan bongino leaving apparently obviously
on mutually mutually okay terms but
there's been a shifting landscape in
media and my question to you is
you think that it's an accident and you
think that there's a concerted effort at
this point you can comment below we'll
sort of make the case it's definitely
been put into overdrive DDOS attacks of
course on Rumble I mean you've seen so
many things going on and also we'll be
talking about the gay throuple I'm sorry
what yeah it's a gay throuple adopting a
child I just I just I don't want to let
people know much more than that
because I think that piques your
interest uh it's a it's a it's a show
Monday through Friday by the way 10 a.m
Eastern if you want to tune in head on
over to rumble if you're watching uh on
YouTube it's live 10 a.m Eastern don't
rely on notifications or any of that
crap all right Gerald hey I really a lot
of people don't know glb because you
haven't missed a day of work in a long
time it's true been replaced yeah my son
was born a year ago and I missed some
work and all of a sudden I'm B yes I'm
doing well how are you I'm good yeah I'm
good yeah we got a fun show today it's
it's one of the funnest shows and we
have the man who uh you know I refer to
him as the goat for a very long time if
you have not seen his stand up
I cannot recommend it enough May 12th
the Hilton Oceanfront
Daytona Beach Florida May 19th 20th
hyenas in Dallas and dear God do not
Heckle do not no it is I mean a part of
me wants you because I want to see that
viral video Nick depalo how are you sir
very good thank you Gerald I have no
kids that I'm in the third seat how do
you think I feel well yeah you made the
choice yes I did a napkin is much easier
but the truth
on here we've replaced it when he's not
there he's replaced with a blow up doll
and the radio we actually have a wig and
people prefer it where do you keep that
how do we get it to the hotel oh believe
me we have plenty I can give you a
loaner
let's be sure to dry clean it just pay
the cleaning fee Nick just pay the
cleaning
I don't know how that works my aunt was
talking about she's in here she's from
Wisconsin she was talking to my dad and
Joe Lewis couldn't go out in the back
because it was muddy she goes just let
it oh my gosh just let him go outside
and my dad goes he's gonna go to Mud he
says put a tarp down I said yeah like we
have a tarp language I got tarps all
over them because you live next to the
averies we don't have tarps laying
around and we certainly don't have 6 000
square feet of tarps no not for a dog
that size anyway okay here's a quick
thing that you guys need to see in case
you haven't been enraged enough the last
two days but this is a transgender
couple well ironically creating sort of
one of the more heterosexual videos I
know unintentionally in a Twist turn but
giving hormones to each other and of
course this is beautiful and brave
[Music]
I'm guessing that's not testosterone
shots
[Music]
that's a nice ass
he used to be a she so
[Music]
I don't even know what that is on the
lips I'm serious well here's the thing
now I do it's meant to play on your you
know emotional strings and they this is
not these people do this this is not
actually the first attempt they tried it
initially with a different song but it
was struck for copyright so where
over the dildo
for the love of God you know I don't
like that type of talk
playing it up huh Stephen this is PG-13
light I know dick always goes he goes
what you're getting mad at me because I
said you did that's the darkest
I've ever seen in my life
you know what 13 13 year old kids are
exposed to on the internet that's true
that standard has to change yeah a
little bit but anyway I don't even know
what it means but uh me either hey it's
beautiful isn't it it's wonderful we're
all supposed to just say yeah isn't that
beautiful what's beautiful about
injecting your spouse with a hormone
that's far into their body well that was
the the correct me if I'm wrong there
was a girl that became a guy and a guy
that became a girl I can't correct you
because I don't know yeah nobody does
the science
uh
the point is the point is whatever's
being injected if they're a man and it's
estrogen cancer it's bad if they're a
woman and it's testosterone who knows
possibly cancer definitely some right
rage yeah okay and no sex well I don't
know well I mean why are you saying that
well if he if if he that became a she
committed then there's no sexual things
down there to have sexy stuff I don't
know they're not monks
that's the thing we don't know how far
they go a lot of these people it's true
over 90 don't go through the bottom half
at least they didn't until before and
most of them just put on a dress and
they say they're barely passable and by
that they mean you're not passable again
that's why I love Caitlyn Jenner just
that's Bruce Jenner in a dress busting
my balls big hairy forearms sound clip
that for Nick next time he's on I love
Caitlyn Jenner I use that whenever it's
I do
records broke that glass ceiling in the
mail decathlon and she said if you're
not laughing at me now when you were a
fan of mine when I was like she right
remember that she said you're crazy if
you're not laughing at me
all right your pumpkin pie haircutted
freak so
how's that Dumb and Dumber that's
Harlan Williams
here
keep your mouth shut if you knew it was
good for you buddy boy uh how's it going
snowball it's a good Halloween she's a
national hero in case I love him hey by
the way if you're watching today you
know it's the end of free mug Club month
and as I'm sure you can imagine
expensive to keep this up yeah bring on
people like Nick that intro doesn't just
uh happen click the button if you're
watching on Rumble today there's a
button right there you just go boom
click it and you get to continue
watching for the remaining hour okay so
this one is right up Gerald's alley uh
because well because you know you're
talking dirty Sports this morning at 6
00 a.m Eastern Joe Biden because that's
when you that's when you announce
important news well that's when he's
halfway through his days yes exactly
he's taking his 40th piss yes he did he
tweeted this from Bob Evans
you hit send Joe
this morning former vice presidents Joe
Biden respect the office former Vice
President Joe Biden announced on Twitter
that he would be running for re-election
and uh this is going to be a bit of a
longer clip because we will go through
it Point by Point dissecting claim and
Truth he announced his new campaign in
video format
Michael Bay
in a world
freedom I try not to Transformers
fundamental who are As Americans when he
said Freedom he just done did his belt
box that's been the work of my first
term to fight for our democracy it
shouldn't be a revolution
to protect our rights to make sure that
everyone in this country is treated
equally and that everyone is given a
fair shot at making it liar bookmark it
we'll get back to it around the country
magnet extremists
Social Security
dictating what health care decisions
women can make Banning books and telling
people who they can love all while
making it more difficult for you to be
able to vote
should be able to shower your daughter
yes and everybody else's daughter
apparently yeah apparently what a dick
nasal decongestants four years ago I
said we're in a battle for the soul of
America and we still are
the question we're facing is whether in
the years ahead we have more freedom or
less friends
he's the freedom guy unbelievable he's
the freedom guy I am my blood pressure I
know I know I can see it it's like
babies right before he died
that's why I'm running for re-election I
don't know why could a BB King
one of my favorite moments by the way
before we move on to the claims of Truth
one of my favorite moments in the
history of this show is yesterday Nick
got so mad I don't remember if it was
Joy Reed oh
nice hairdo you
[Laughter]
but here's the thing let's go through
this okay let's go through this point by
point the claims that he makes here's a
claim that former Vice President Joe
Biden makes in there that freedom is
integral to Biden's ethos first off uh
click like if you're watching on YouTube
right now and you know that everything
that guy just said is okay
because here's the truth yeah Joe Biden
former vice president is all about
Freedom unless you want to start a
business of course because he added uh
regulations that are unprecedented or if
you want to protect yourself or your
family with a firearm or if you believe
in parental rights and you don't want to
transition your children or of course if
uh you know you believe that you should
be able to drive a car that uses the
evil fossil fuel so outside of that he's
all about Freedom also if your credit
score is a little too high you're going
to be punished for it so it's Freedom if
you understand that freedom means it's
not why
did I miss anything I think you covered
just about all of that all right yeah
you can always jump in Gerald if you
have it yeah I thought I thought you had
a point there no okay here's another
claim I'm looking at you for this one
Gerald we're going to downgrade you to
see Biden says that he was fighting for
democracy or he has been fighting for
democracy former Vice President Biden
okay here's the truth
and all of these references are made
publicly available so that you can fact
check us he signed 22 executive orders
in the first week the most since the
1970s the majority of those is a good
point to jump in the majority of those
were actually just to undo Trump right
all the stuff that Trump did first one
Keystone XL pipeline so if you want to
be energy independent he's not so much
your guy well you're also free to pay
you know twice the amount for gas that's
a freedom yeah free to pay more for
everything it's Freedom if you don't
actually qual if you don't use the
definition of freedom you know it's just
we're changing them like male female
it's not a thing anymore and I think if
the research team can grab it I think he
did a hundred and he signed 160 in his
first year there's about 160 in the
first year so we wanted to have a good
comparison for you yeah compared to
Obama and Trump I think it was Obama's
35 and 35 was like 55. yeah so so that's
I'm not a math Asian but three times as
much that is three times but I think the
key point that they made here was that
typically in the first week you may get
one two three of these
22 yeah the first thing he did when he
he walked into the Oval Office
essentially was revoke the Keystone
Pipeline approval yeah and have them
have them involved toddler scratch and
sniffs he doesn't even like the
executive orders have it's almost like
they have nothing to do with policy
seven of the exactly they were Banning
kids from the Oval Office which he
repealed immediately but I don't know I
don't have a degree in political science
so don't take my word for it
uh then he blew something up he banned
at the Bible yeah exactly that no no no
no no allegedly alleged we have no idea
who did that no no you're actually right
I mean you know yeah Nordstrom blew
itself up Jacques cousteau's ghost
he was looking for the spotted octopus
or something yeah I don't know what this
is so energy Independence not time I
watch
Jesse Jesse Ventura I was in an
underwater demolition fine thanks Jesse
here's another claim that he makes in
his video that he wants to make sure
everyone is treated equally oh boy
when buying this I mean I'm at the point
where nope is anyone buying this if
you're watching on Rumble smash the
rumble button here it's it's and you can
comment below does this actually work
with anybody because here's the thing if
you look at the Democratic voters
they're not demanding more freedom or
choice this is as I've said the left
Biden Democrats always have to run as
centrists they always have to present as
centrists in order to be elected
contrast that with the right if you look
at even the primary right now DeSantis
you look at Trump they have to present
themselves to be as conservative as
possible and do the same in a general
election otherwise they stand no chance
at winning one side is actually
incentivized to deceive you so he says
he wants to make sure that everyone is
treated equally okay here's the truth
former Vice by former Vice President
Biden's justice department right it
urged the Supreme Court to drop the
affirmative action case against Harvard
from Asian Americans where uh you know
Asians said hey Harvard told us we're
full up too many of you uh deservingly
are scoring off the charge and we're
going to reject you from the schools
because affirmative action unfortunately
bit them in the ass when Asians who come
from strong family households who value
studying hard getting good grades they
were being denied entry they were being
discriminated against based on their
race then Biden said no no let's keep
that going
let's keep you Asians out of higher
education and then they blame us for
saying that we are promoting hate
towards Asians I'm like you literally
want them to have a worse life because
they don't get the education they
deserve isn't it freeing to just be
consistent to say that's a meritocracy I
don't care if you're Asian if you're
black if you're white you get the best
grades you get going to college they
have to say no no but if you're black
but if you're Asian but not if you're
two age if you do too well as an Asian
it can never be consistent because
progress for Progress sake has to
self-destruct are we the only ones
seeing these inconsistencies you want to
believe the the rest of the country is
that stupid no and if they are you know
they always on Trump supporters
yeah how about us people who support
this well you know in this poop
I've said it several times I mean
come on that's not better yeah I don't
know is it supporting this uh feces the
romance languages I don't know where it
comes from uh this stool sale no but you
know what it's a good good point here's
sort of a contrast people on the right
expect some kind of truth from their
candidates people on the left they know
that do you think any Democrat
no I really don't I mean the younger
kids are so brain they've been
marinating in this craps yeah but they
don't they don't vote in master they
don't vote enough people do right so
when they do something like this they're
like oh here's what happens oh they must
know better than I do it's social
engineering yeah Asian hate from the
left so we have to support Asians in
just about every single thing they do
unless we talk about black on Asian
crime and then we have to stand out of
the way because that's the other
minority Olympic game that oppression
Olympics that we have to play and then
by the way minority Olympics uh the
blacks always win they do yes in actual
Olympics I should say in minority
Olympics the trans women but an actual
Olympics oppression Olympics on the
other hand it's just bad in a black guy
yeah exactly unless it's World's
Strongest Man then it's Iceland go ahead
but then they do the school thing and
they go oh well they must know best of
course we don't want just Asians to go
to this week we need diversity not
diversity of thought diversity of skin
color that's what they want yeah no I
understand your point Nick but here's
the thing I think this is the unwritten
agreement between former Vice President
Biden and his voter base is going you
know that I don't really mean this but I
have to appeal to them middle enough to
win an election whereas again with
Donald Trump or DeSantis or whoever the
nominee is they have to make sure that
their base trusts them would you vote
for a republican like a Lindsey Graham
or Mitch McConnell you probably wouldn't
vote not with a guy has no Chin yes
exactly and Lindsey Graham yeah that
goes back to Harlan Williams here he
goes
um
and we're seeing him live that's my
favorite joke he goes I like to cook I
uh recently I bought a five pound base
beef tongue and I cooked it in vegetable
oil you know what I call that dish let
my Gracie ass that's the joke
it's
[Music]
I freaking love that good no I think
that they have to appeal to this sort of
Middle Ground whereas a conservatives
have to appeal to the base to some
degree and I love that you can comment
below if you think that I'm wrong I
think Nick brings up a valid point I
just see the world uh
similarly but differently I'm probably
uh you know more angry at beneath the
surface than Nick but his is there for
all to see which is fun uh so van hotter
Taxi
so here's the truth as well another
truth right we just talked about the
Harvard case Biden invited this of
course black shooting victim Ralph yarl
to the White House not invited
six-year-old Kinsley white white girl
who was shot for trying to retrieve a
basketball so you have the empirical as
a matter of policy of course he supports
equity and I've been very clear about
this you can either support equality or
Equity you cannot support both equality
means equality of opportunity Equity
means insured outcomes which has to
forbid equal opportunity for certain
groups like Asians in Harvard yes
exactly and people that have the last
name white and happen to also be white
the problem there with that last one
though is that it was a black man who
shot her father her and I think one
other person was hit by some kind of a
fragment in their family as well this
person was shot by a black man no
headlines black man shoots white girl
but in the previous story white man
shoots black guy yeah they want to draw
attention to it and they wanted to paint
well white man shoots black guy it's a
novelty so they like it it's a
statistical novelty let's be honest here
as far as interracial crime I mean I
know the doj stopped recording the
victims of the crimes of perpetrators or
at least they stopped recording
interracial crime statistics you can get
the perpetrator or the victim but not
both they used to register them
accurately so there's a novelty of you
know of of a white man shooting a black
man despite what you believe um it's
actually not nearly as common here's
another claim in Biden's wonderful
rambling video that Republicans want to
control women's bodies he wants to
control the world they're right there
he wants to control the water
temperature for girls in the showers I
like it cold
and they said this isn't real and then
they decided to raid James O'Keefe going
okay all right but it's real that you
stole it he's like I didn't steal it
like wow the story's passed
wait did she shower with her dad the
former vice president yeah
oh is that what is that a serious
question yes
so his claim is that Republicans want to
control women's body here's the truth
Dobbs versus Jackson the most egregious
example that they want to give you ever
the Supreme Court decision it returned
abortion to the states women are still
free to abort a baby in a majority of
states and then other states that think
you know if a baby is viable for example
or if unlike Virginia they don't believe
up until and including birth or after
birth period they're free to implement
the laws that they want to and just so
you know that this is true you can see
their rhetoric where now they have
abortion tourism so they know that there
are states that have radically
pro-abortion laws and people are leaving
their state to go get abortions
performed in those states which of
course they want to subsidize on the
left so their arguments hold no water
when you see their own arguments that
they make depending on the audience at
any given time I think you said uh you
meant to say that we are depriving
people of healthcare Stephen because yes
yes that's that's the commonly used way
off yeah I apologize so you guys can
admonish me we're depriving women of
Health Care yes it's science because I
saw Nick just standing front of the
clinic just slapping insulin needles out
of a beast bitch's hand just like get
out of here
health care nothing more healthy than
sticking a coat hanger in a kid's eye
sockets exactly yeah no it's hey yeah
that's a that's an anti-abortion joke
it's the new women's gym it's curved
hangers
Jenny clump of cells so here's another
claim
weight removers we can go all day
here's another claim uh that Republicans
want to tell people who they can love
which is I know so stupid I know a lot
of you are angry that I'm addressing it
and I want to kick my own ass but I kind
of have to because he said I started it
so here's does that again com does
anyone actually believe this do you
actually believe that Republicans want
to tell people who they can love even if
you could go back to the most homophobic
redneck who didn't think that queer
should get made and you guys all wanted
to label him hateful he doesn't care who
they love yeah so Elton John believed in
civil unions because he said marriage is
for boring heterosexual peoples there is
no Republican who wants to tell you who
you can love some of them think it's
gross
here's the truth Biden is I'm guessing
referring to a Florida bill that prevent
you know don't say gay bill which by the
way appears nowhere in that bill correct
it just says that you cannot teach
hyper-sexualized issues right here's the
actual wording instruction from the
classroom by school or Personnel or
third parties on sexual orientation or
gender identity may not occur in
kindergarten through grade three or in a
matter that is not that age-appropriate
that's okay through three I know to
eight-year-olds exactly that's going too
far how about how about the 21. yeah
exactly we all knew about our sex lives
yeah can you tell me that you're great
can you tell me how you plowed your
partner over the weekend yeah exactly
how's it going to get it in the sandbox
yeah we all remember our Second Grade
Center behind the monkey bars handing
out dick pics with the stencils geez yes
in the world can fight for something
like this and not be viewed as a
despicable person or pedophile like how
can you be like well no kindergarten
kids okay need to be able to hear about
the sex lives of their teachers I feel
like I've been tossing to you the viewer
too much today but I would really love
to see you comment below don't you think
former Vice President Joe Biden's a
pedophile like come on and your heart of
hearts don't you think he's an actual
pedophile
well sniffing uh sniffing for pert
or Herbal Essence hurt plus kids No More
Tears not what I'm through with you oh
exactly
that's a big yes yeah I think everyone
thinks so it's enough that he was doing
with your kids what he does with other
people's kids you'd want to kick his ass
and so people say hey are they coming
freaking well maybe not everyone's
coming for my kids just the former Vice
President Joe Biden I have to lock up
the shower
and by the way the Bible Administration
is just to be clear in the contrast to
that forcing a notably lgbtq AI agenda
on America by appointing lgbtq activism
not because they are but actually in
spite of the fact that they are
supremely underqualified and have a long
and stored history of being bad at their
jobs he also by the way told Dylan
Mulvaney that not the person responsible
for Bud Light sales uh tanking that uh
not transitioning kids is immoral I
think that it's really important that
shut up continue to speak on about the
basic fundamental rights of all human
beings and the idea oh my God the idea
that nurse
in some states I won't get to know of
the politics of it but in some states
it's just it's outrageous and I think
it's immoral the transport's not immoral
oh you had it right what they're trying
to do to trans persons is immoral and
what he means by try to do is parental
rights where you have the right to
prevent your six seven eight-year-old
child from permanently rendering
themselves infertile
[Music]
okay that means that we're still live on
Rumble because I just slipped up because
I was watching that and I don't know how
to even Mr Burns in the corn fields
that's what that looks like right there
the dump button we actually keep track
of when we hit it and it's just like
going down the list now because every
time we're on you oh yes yeah there's no
good why are you watching on YouTube
anyway go to rumble yeah head on over to
rumble jeez even though there have been
of course DDOS attacks because of how no
one said Rumble has become so that shows
that you guys are doing something right
Biden is not only a liar uh and a failed
former vice president no one wants him
to run again
this is from CNN 70 of Americans
51 percent of Democrats holy cow just to
be clear 51 of Democrats one percent of
Democrats and he's not going to
impressive you can't get 51 of Democrats
to agree on anything outside of
castration he's not going to make it you
don't think he will he's going to get up
to piss the middle of the night trip on
something bust his head on the tub I'm
telling you he is I'm I'll bet anybody
here all right they're going to come up
with something they're not going to come
up with something I think he probably
has one of those tubs that the door
opens that they sell right I wanted one
of those he hoverounds to the Grand
Canyon I want that and acorn stairlift
yes
come on Chef face
that's exactly what the hell is Mount
Charles it's a club I just played
the bathtub with the door yes like it's
like it looks like someone just came out
of that room from Event Horizon and
Biden's case it probably looks very much
the same I lift my leg now to get in the
tub you see your balls on the mirror
look like a great dance now why do you
have a look like Joe Lewis but if you're
getting you're lifting you're like that
would mean you have a mirror in the
bottom of your tub I do who are you Joe
Budden yes he loves my niece lives right
under me yes exactly I thought there was
something odd with the mirrored Shoes by
the way you know how most people
announce their re-election Stadium a
tour that's a good giant crowd of pizza
that's a good point Biden did a video
where they're like can you just use a
lot of what I did say already so I don't
have to say it again I can't say that
many words yeah there's a there's a
there's a marathon of Matlock
remember his campaign there was like
four Toyotas out there yeah one person
each I bet she gets confused when he
watches Matt like matlock's in a car
chase what holy hell where's Perry Mason
yeah
by the way smash the rubble button if
you are watching on Rumble because uh we
want as many people to go over there as
possible no one really wants you on
YouTube and No at some point we won't be
there at all now here's the other thing
before his announcement uh Biden made
his most and a lot of times people throw
this term around I mean it would I say
communist I mean
communist a communist statement as as
close to Communism as I've ever seen
from an American former vice president
to date Rebecca put a teacher's Creed
into words when she said there's no such
thing sounds like Maverick I know
no such thing as someone else's child
our nation's children are all our
children ah there's no such thing as
someone else's child well an interview
it takes a village to raise a child and
so that's how uh that's how we deal with
it there with former Vice President
Biden yeah they're good good to the draw
there to a man the kid looks happy I
remember the Village People having Coney
in it I don't know what that means they
expanded and you know what actually Nick
you made this point yesterday and so we
decided to sort of reiterate it for
people who missed yesterday's show uh a
lot of you were saying why why are they
doing this why are they trying to
destroy these institutions and it starts
with destroying the family nuclear
family or a really big enemy because
before and I've talked about this before
before you have federal government
before you have state government
municipal government you have
self-governance and that can only happen
through the family that's why there were
laws to encourage families that's why
there are tax incentives to encourage
families because a strong family unit
encourages a moral society and we fail
to have a society that can function
without strong family units and that's
why you hear the rhetoric from the left
it takes a village there is no other
person's child and then of course they
want the government to take your
children away if you don't transition
them now here's something you may not
know marks and Engels they were huge
proponents of abolishing the family unit
that as a matter of fact was step number
one let me read you a quote and this one
doesn't include the n-word from Karl
Marx like we you know he loved using
that we had to search through a lot of
quotes
foreign
what Foundation is the present family is
a Bourgeois family based on Capital on
private gain in its completely developed
forms the family exists only among the
bourgeoisie the Bourgeois family will
vanish as a matter of course when its
completement vanishes and both will
vanish with the vanishing of capital
they wanted no family unit and you just
heard Biden say there's no such thing as
someone else's kid actually there is
mine why because you shower with yours
when she was reading Teen Beat well and
look every every kind of desperate
leader who's trying to completely change
society has tried to use this so there's
kind of these famous stories in Cambodia
when I was over there I found out about
this I had no idea how terrifying The
Killing Fields were there was over a
million people killed everybody was
pushed out of the Cities into the
countryside and what the government
actually did there was a chilling scene
in I think the Killing Fields the movie
that came out it basically showed a kid
walking up to a chalkboard sorry my
pants wrote up you're fine people you
can't you don't have your pants right up
when the scene gets in the wrong place
I'm sorry go ahead talk about the
killing field camera it's killing
they're killing my balls there was there
was a chalkboard with stick figures of a
family like two two adults and two kids
but they were all holding hands and a
child walks up grabs the Eraser and
erases the hand-holding between the
parents and the children and the state
officer starts cleaning basically your
loyalty is not to parents there is no
family your loyalty is to the state yeah
there is nobody else that you should be
loyal to or take direction from it's
chilling to think about that as parents
yeah that the state tries to make it
their job it's an important Point Cheryl
that wasn't the Killing Fields that was
porkies too yes and they were they were
cambodians or big Will Smith fans
parents just don't understand
and then you get slapped
there's no such thing as someone else's
kid that was uh John Wayne Gacy's quote
in his yearbook in high school and he
didn't clown makeup
uh
there is nobody wants former Vice
President Joe Biden to run again you can
correct me if you think I'm wrong his
campaign video is inaccurate verifiably
in almost every single front says he
cares about personal freedom that's a
lie says he stands for democracy that's
a lie says he wants everyone to be
created equally that's a lie especially
if you're Asian if you're white he says
that Republicans are trying to control
women's bodies when that's not true he
says Republicans care about who you love
that's not true he wants to control
people on top of all that he is openly
advocating for communist ideas right out
in the open like you have no parental
rights and your children are not your
own did I miss anything if I did miss
anything comment below if I didn't hit
the like buttons that the algorithm gets
us in front of people who actually may
need to see it but they probably won't
anyway even if you enter in the title
on YouTube that is yeah run Rumble they
do it oh on Rumble it's fun on Rumble
you get to actually see what it is that
you want God I wish I knew what you guys
have talked about
something something family
I mean the tech part sure Don Lemon oh
yeah Don Lemon what happened to that
I guess it's appropriate monkey pox so
proud no that's passe that's pasta is
that that's already gone what's that
rash in my balls it's very easily
avoidable if you want monkey pox you
kind of have to make an appointment
where stand in line Norwegian techno
music fest
the only way it was like three guys yeah
make it you know yeah Christopher Sam
Kennison the bed he got in trouble for
yeah people don't yeah the age where he
said yeah it gotten shuttle because of
the last special I said uh that they're
uh aren't any straight people who get
AIDS people said there are a lot of
straight celebrities who get AIDS oh
yeah
that was it
I think Elton John that was a woodchuck
and Elton John was there or some
that's when he became one of my favorite
comments they won he threw it out oh
didn't need the mic for that yeah that
was him back then just like monkey pox
although I would like to go back and
investigate the golden retriever with
monkey pox yeah the gay couples golden
retriever yeah who also developed a
latex allergy I'm just saying it seems
like where there's smoke there's it's
like the monkey pox slogan is monkey pox
you really gotta want it yeah
that's great
I'd say mark it down for a sketch but no
one will know what we're talking about
because it hasn't been in the news sorry
I brought it up remember they said it
was going to be the next big pandemic
how about shingles everybody well some
people get it
but it's just funny
oh yeah I mean it's funny for the rest
of us not the purpose and had shingles
well that's not funny oh my God what was
his name
somewhere over the deal though hey that
was you shingles ding
who's that guy who does that and I don't
know he's like let me take somewhere
over the rainbow and make it you know
it's a good song that's good I don't
know I just don't need to hear it over
every graduation after vitamin C okay so
yeah
and lemon that
Nick depolo said uh I
was a proud gay very gay black man and
fake journalist he was canned by CNN but
it gets funnier
Leo's I'm listening to you talk I'm
looking at our feed here internally and
Don Lemon is now tweeting that he has
been informed that he has been
terminated by CNN did anyone see this
one coming look he's waiting for the uh
wow
um well I knew that um you don't know we
just told you Colby and I'm stunning
come back to the guy the gay Clerk and I
was at Bloomingdale's Moscow on the
Hudson oh my God he's defecting I really
wish she would have said that to him you
know call me I just told you I got that
from Uncle Junior on the surprise I did
so here's the thing the way it was
handled was uh of course the only way it
could be which was caddy back and forth
so yeah CNN issued a statement saying we
wish him well we'll be chewing him on in
his future endeavors and then Don Lemon
immediately had his own statement
afterwards and he's like I'm stunned
after 17 years at CNN I would have
thought that someone in management would
have had the decency to tell me directly
so then CNN was like yeah go screw
yourself his statement this morning uh
was inaccurate and so you you know take
take a hike you silly you silly
generically ethnically ambiguous homo
that's what they said and I don't I
don't know lying even on the out
going out the door I know he was one
like the view was saying that's a little
too much yeah it's just it's gonna get
too catty
[Music]
that is absolutely perfect until I
passed English my teacher love that
so Don Lemon hurts uh CNN's numbers at
prime time they move into morning he's
he's like he's the Dylan mulvania it's
only gayer
I know it's possible that's what he is
you're absolutely right they're just
they can't they're like well we just
can't keep hemorrhaging viewers I mean
they were moving this guy around the
same thing with Anderson Cooper big
still in Mobility look like Aaron
Rodgers yes
after 17 years of sucking see I had a
prime time show that almost failed so
they put me in the morning for a while
they actually took me off of that
because I heard terrible morning numbers
how did you pause that you possibly see
it coming what do you think uh what do
you think made you do so poorly well I
make Anderson Cooper look like Jimmy the
Greek
he's really tiny yeah he's absolutely
tiny and anyway this isn't going to go
anywhere but the point is they suck
Laura Vanderbilt six three two six he
wasn't she I have no idea that's his mom
that's true right don't get me started
on the Sarah Lee Fortune so uh Don's
firing and this is going to bring us to
Tucker Carlson which you're probably
more interested in but the sort of I
guess I would say odd time and
coincidental timing and look let me be
clear about this I'm not reveling in the
fact that Don lemon's you know career
isn't going I actually like having these
people when Chris Cuomo was on air Brian
stelter because I think it's important
for people to see all points of view and
what I don't want to have happen is all
of this sort of merge into a fake you
know unbiased Middle Ground of news
which we know not to be true Let your
freak flag fly let everybody see it but
in any event uh we're sad to see Don
Lemon leave and the least that we could
do is honor him uh of course with his
very own time to close nothing but the
utmost respect for my friends at ABC and
other things well for me an automatic
weapon is something that you can shoot
off a number of rounds that was good
sorry you know there are ways not to
perform oral sex if you all I want to do
this I'm not person I know people think
that I'm some liberal Democrat I'm not I
say that the biggest Terror threat in
this country comes from radicals on the
far right I'm the smartest man on
television
time to
close
endings and Beginnings are ending and
beginning now I should probably drink a
lot more than I do he has his hand and
his pants rubbing himself aggressively
and he shoves his two fingers up
underneath my mustache thrusts my head
back or whatever ethnicity you are
explaining to me what it's like to be
black whatever ethnicity I'll tell you
what I am I'm an Indian American
[Music]
what are we in junior high school like
what the hell what is this
I'm Nikki Haley is in a prime sorry when
a woman is considered being her Prime in
her 20s and 30s and maybe 40s that's not
according to me I cannot keep a thought
if you guys are talking to me in my ear
so hang on one second so to say that
that black people would say what you
said again I never watched Don Lemon who
I once called the dumbest man on
television
bad reporting that need to be answered
from real journalists I shouldn't say
that uh
[Music]
time
time things to close
I know that it's time for things to
close
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
you said the word of the day Jews
bet you they're gonna find him in a
dirty theater somewhere that guy got a
bad rap that really wasn't fair he was
in a dirty theater Paul Rubens and it's
like okay that's not that big of a deal
the point is I mean it's a little bit of
a big deal but it's kind of that's where
you go to do that kind of I take it over
blippi so yeah we actually been the low
Cineplex yeah well Frozen two came up
well Elsa
so uh this moves us to Tucker Carlson
um we covered this yesterday where it
broke and we were all kind of surprised
uh as to when this broke there wasn't a
lot of information uh and I think we
actually have a clip of us reacting
yesterday Live to when it happened but
now there are some some updates and I
think it's part of a larger picture we
have breaking news right now Fox News
and taco Carlson are going to part ways
what get out of here Tucker Carlson's
Gonna Leave Fox News not just like the
crappy streaming service Fox but
actually Fox News not just Fox Nation
but like the actual show Fox news media
and Tucker Carlson have agreed to part
ways Mr Carlson's last program was on
Friday April 21st so it's done well he's
going to political
I don't even know why that's funny yeah
I know how does that even happen I would
think they'd have people around so
here's what we know now okay so the Los
Angeles Times reports and that doesn't
really mean that it's necessarily true
but I'm just letting you know that
Carlson was pushed out by Rupert Murdoch
so uh we have an overlay there from all
the references are available at lotto's
credit.com uh the firing they say is
related to a discrimination lawsuit by
Carlson's former booking producer and
Murdoch reportedly was uncomfortable
with Carlson's January 6th reporting now
let me be clear about this whether you
like Tucker or you don't this is one
thing where all conservatives should be
supporting him yeah the fact that he had
the balls to cover I mean we did it long
long before that of course ongoing we
did a full stream on January 6th but we
knew there was a third rail for media we
accepted the strikes on YouTube so for
someone like Tucker Carlson I know that
he was up against it at the news Corps
offices and I have an immense amount of
respect for that guy's clanging
pendulous balls so this is a quote uh
from the LA Times it says Murdoch was
also said to be concerned over Carlson's
coverage of the Jan 6 2021 Insurrection
this is what they say Insurrection at
the U.S Capitol in which the host has
promoted the conspiracy theory that was
provoked by government agents
um I I don't know how do you say
conspiracy theory when it's half of the
kidnappers in the Whitmer plot when they
admitted that there were government
agents there that not only were there
federal agents there were federal agents
not just in trapping committing crimes
breaking through the barricade now we
don't know how many of them were
government agents we don't know if Ray
Epps was a government agent it's now a
matter of record and there is no doubt
that there were government agents there
on January 6 and they were actively
committing the crime of trespassing
see media if if Murdoch and news Corps
has a problem with Tucker going with
that that means that they will not allow
people to step out of line with opinions
they don't like this is not a matter of
debate it's a matter of public record
yeah and everybody was asking the
question about Epps everybody was
talking about like what's going on with
this guy here we have footage and we
even covered it we had footage of course
saying hey we're gonna go start the
capital and they're like fat fat right
they were calling about the day before
so it wasn't like the media started that
yeah it was people there that started it
and we just reported on it and he got
charged with nothing right
on the FBI's most wanted list one day
and not the next or something yeah they
cleared them up three seconds well you
hear the story now there's companies
like I was just a trump supporter who
was there like I'll cure you right yeah
okay that's why you're on Most Wanted
you disappeared you ran away from now I
don't know right ups but here's the
thing we don't need to get into that no
there were other federal agents period
it has been widely acknowledged we just
don't know how many and we know that
they were committing the crimes of
trespassing you know who we know did not
commit trespassing was the Q Anon Shaman
who by the way was likely freed because
of some of the public pressure from
Tucker Carlson so when people say oh
what are you doing you're just talking
hey I don't know if you know this Tucker
Carlson covering that that probably
helped that guy who was being held right
in a violation of his rights probably
helped him get out yes saved him years
behind bars there's importance behind
words it's not just about when it comes
time to shooting for people who live out
that fantasy it's not just Red Dawn
guess what shining a light on something
the one thing that these people hate
more than anything meaning the left
meaning the media political
entertainment industrial complex is
sunlight Tucker did that in a lot of
ways by the way Fox they lost 930
million in market value after announcing
uh Tucker's departure if I'm not
mistaken is that the number yeah it is
they rebounded slightly after that but
yeah there was a huge dip on the
announcement right or his Bud Light
calls a good day
that's all you lost and you know sadly
CNN actually lost their final 23 viewers
at the uh Provincetown airport so
they're both they're all feeling this
thing wow yeah stuck went up 200 million
gone lemon
took a powder anyways
all right were you about to say
something Nick just did no okay so many
terrible shows and no one to see it I
know I know what are they talking right
now on CNN they're talking about the
Santa potential candidates for president
do they not know how to dress this broad
honestly and it's perfect she's got a
men's suit on the 48 inch neck
it's like Paul Stanley you're you're
gonna like the way you look
wear a warehouse
she walks in hen can we direct you to
our Bam Bam Bigelow section
don't you prefer Jimmy superfoot snooka
and Tucker also has and this is going to
bring us afterwards to curious uh
coincidences but Tucker's firing has
leftists like AOC
and this is why we say like I I'm not
Don Lemon was fired because his ratings
were bad let's understand the difference
here right Don lemon's ratings were
terrible no matter where he went Prime
Time bad morning bad he was ratings
cancer Tucker brought in record Rings he
did incredibly well the issue is the
boycotting from giant giant leftist
Corporation so there's a huge difference
between the market determining that your
show is not successful and deliberately
trying to remove someone simply because
they have points of view that you
dislike and so that's why it's I don't
want to say unsettling it's expected but
of course it's aggravating to people
like AOC giddy with excitement at the
idea of a corporate censorship
Tucker Carlson is out at Fox News
couldn't have happened to a better guy
liar liar and you know it what I will
say though is
go ahead I'm very glad that the person
that was arguably responsible for the
give me a margarita some of the largest
driving some of the most uh amounts of
death threats and violent threats not
just to my office but to plenty of
people like the pipe bomb that was never
placed in the office you were never in
like she was six buildings away yeah for
the cut scene at the end of a Marvel
movie after all the credits have rolled
and then you see like the villains like
hand
re-emerge out to glip grip over like the
end of a building or something are you a
throat but
deep platforming works and it is
important eyes on the road
there you go she's driving things can
happen oh no come on she has a show
first she appears as though she's one of
them she's driving with her paws her
hind legs her hooks her Hooves thank you
whoops you guys are all on the ball
today uh D platforming works there you
go this is what they want to be clear I
don't want de-platforming of anyone that
I disagree with I want you to see the
different points of you and let the
cards fall where they may they want
people to be removed and then they never
debate the ideas and by the way AOC the
danger here is even though she can do it
she's already inspiring young leftists
across the country with now many others
calling for d platforming uh including
other people on Tick Tock and of course
directing it at prominent right-wing
figures so I'm sure y'all have seen boss
babes aoc's new Instagram story and I
just want to hop on here and say that
she is completely right de-platforming
works and I think it's time we start
using our feminine voices inspire a real
change in this world
and if I'm being honest I don't really
know who Tucker Carlson is nor do I
really care but his 1995 Tommy Hilfiger
look tacky AF so I think it's good thing
that he's gone
anyways I don't think we should stop
with him I think our next Target needs
to be Elon Musk for three reasons one
because he's white gross two he's from
Africa and they're like really poor
there and three his cars don't even work
I tried filling out my Tesla Roadster
the other day and I couldn't find the
gas hole so I just put it on the engine
because like what else am I supposed to
do
so I started a new hashtag hashtag no
more Africans so we can get him
impeached from being the president of
the Senate anyways until next time bye
and by the way keep your compliments in
the chat
and a Nick keep them tasteful because we
understand how adorable Riley is okay
we're very protective of Our Ladies here
sexy I don't want to hear that
there's no Lefty that looks like that no
exactly I still have no five o'clock
shadow no giant forehead somewhere she
must be a new Lefty yeah she is she's
from the new level well she made three
lefts and so she's back right there you
go I think that's how it works I don't
know I had a remote control car uh so
here's the thing if Tucker's exit seems
a little fishy and we don't have all the
information
you're not alone and that brings us to I
want to kind of walk through the other
instances that have been very similar to
this because the leftists of the D
platforming works it's time for Curious
coincidences
foreign
[Music]
ER because it's like I have a chest I
have a chest burp that isn't quite there
yet but when it is I'll just hit the
I'll just hit the button so let's go
through
coincidence have you noticed this Nick
like the the kind of pattern here of of
conservative commentators and figures
who've been getting de-platformed or
attacked at an increasing rate the last
two months yeah lends more Credence to
my theory there's 10 people in a room
yeah uh eight of them are trans one is
gay and one's a Puerto Rican uh with a
full headdress I don't know what they're
doing Puerto Rican they could be
Dominican I'm just saying yeah
this is definitely a global movement
okay I'm nervous about it how could you
not be in there but could you
acknowledge that they could be Dominican
I'm just saying it could be I just don't
want to be admonished they could be
Puerto Rican they could be Dominican I
don't know I say Dominican so
coincidence number one okay we have
Tucker he was fired but this comes right
after uh less than a week I guess after
Fox part of ways with Dan bongino now I
know Dan bongino said hey no ill will
and and that's likely true but it it
also doesn't really seem to make a lot
of sense Dan bongino for people whether
you like him or don't like him he's a
consistent conservative he's been a
friend of the show yeah the guy
absolutely has a backbone he's willing
to say things that by the way certainly
would ruffle some feathers from sort of
the milk toast people on the right so I
don't necessarily it's a pattern that
you're seeing it's got a pretty good
following too as of some of the other
you know he's here on Rumble actually
right now if you're right there I'm sure
there's probably a link you can watch
him on on Rumble because I think he was
uh removed from YouTube not long ago
well an understanding that he needed
another place to be able to go it's like
there you go absolutely isn't it
isn't that Murdoch's kid who's the
problem I blame it on the younger I
don't rest I mean Suzanne Scott get yeah
put a fella in there I have to be
careful because
you what like I said she's a good
broadcast yeah yeah there you go and
he's terrific too no the thing is the
thing is what am I on ABC no no I just
said you know I don't want to get sued
oh I don't know I don't know how to get
sued but uh take over your briefs
whatever you just said
yeah so
well for a lot for a couple deniability
I didn't listen to what Nick says I
never did I don't know what's going on
so I said yes not knowing but so
coincidence number two uh look Matt
Walsh was hacked last week in case yeah
in case you don't know that which look
again this is not about who you
personally like or dislike I know there
are a lot of conservatives who like Matt
Walsh most do I know there are a lot of
people who he rubs in the wrong way it
doesn't matter you shouldn't Revel in
the jewel you shouldn't Revel in the
hacking and leaking of private
information this is a concerted effort
and a violation of privacy it's a crime
okay let's also go to coincidence number
three we have James O'Keefe was forced
out from Project very to us at the end
of February and here's the thing if you
look at it again whether you like James
O'Keefe or not it does the worst thing
it seems like he did was he maybe took
someone sandwiched from the fridge well
and uh he had the audacity to use a
private plane to go raise millions of
dollars from donors so he could
make the trip possible yeah come on so
this is what happens with the
personalities who you have right
you have four there are three that we
have well but you're actually missing
one
you oh myself yeah this has been
happening for a long time it's it's
maybe it's because it's happened for the
last yeah I know all the leaks been yeah
they always happen coincidence oh you
forget another one Pat Robertson they're
pushing on him he can leg press 1100
pounds wow
oh yeah someone bring up uh bring up
that over labor he's like I like press
uh 1100 pounds and he has knee wraps he
has wrist straps and he's putting his
hands on his leg he's like uh for Jesus
that's true he said he could only do 850
then Jesus came into life right up there
exactly he turned he turned his water
into pre-workout
Place
Jesus gave me a spot yeah and for
Recovery his final Miracle the
never-ending possible that Olive Garden
old people love Bob Evans and Olive
Garden Blue Plate specialist so Tucker
bongino although that wasn't really a
hack obviously Matt Walsh hacks James
O'Keefe ousted you uh yeah and then uh
you have a coincidence number four
Tucker's firing by the way it also comes
immediately after Fox settled this uh
lawsuit with Dominion something else you
may not know coincidence number five
Rumble has been under Relentless DDOS
attacks since we've gone over and this
is what happens rather than covering the
numbers rather than covering what
actually happens you know this
Monumental shift notice you don't really
see it at places like Media Matters or
Daily Beast what happens is there are
attacks behind the scenes like yesterday
where the view counter was like Ed
Rooney's attendance computer
so Rumble and here's the beauty of
Rumble though they understand this and
they're building it out so they are
dependent on no one else that just takes
more time uh but they have been subject
to Relentless DDOS attacks hopefully
today this is still up there right now
if you're watching hit the rumble button
and uh let them know that you love them
comment on Rumble because it happens at
least once a week where there's a
concerted effort all of this at one time
at what point do you say hey this is a
coincidence when the left like AOC these
people are saying hey D platforming
really works one side demands
transparency one side precludes it yeah
and you know what the guys over there so
crazy I was on the phone with him a lot
yesterday and then Chris and his team of
engineer years they basically just work
around the clock around these things
fixed so thank you guys for the work
you're doing because look it's hard to
set this up it's not hard because you
have to compete that's hard enough right
it's not hard because the game's not
fair that's hard enough right it's not
hard because the government's all
against you and they want you to lose
it's hard because when you start to win
other people start to try to take you
down not competing fairly by attacking
you behind the scenes by making your
Tech hard by making your life hard yeah
so thanks for all the work guys we
really do appreciate it and by the way
this is something that's very common I
was speaking with a lawyer who has
represented some of the biggest clients
in in Hollywood yeah the most common
thing let me ask you this if you're
watching like Matt Walsh okay my heart
really goes out to the guy uh does
anyone out there does anyone out there
would you want every single one of your
private texts or emails or search
history to be available to the public no
think about that that doesn't mean
you're doing anything illegal no but
don't you
it's not like Thomas
oh God
I mean you know it's a violation of your
privacy there are people so there was a
celebrity an A-list female star this is
a story that was uh related Roosevelt
Kathy Griffin Paris Hilton yeah I don't
know you're probably like we're in
Deborah Winger territory until like two
years ago this is not nearly as very
Advanced we bet on the wrong person
she's no Annette Benning
um so this is a this is a top star
someone broke into this person's house
this is pre-internet stole nude pictures
oh that's right stole nude pictures of
this woman and was going to reveal them
to the public now here's the thing
that's a crime but the person who did
this was so confident that this
celebrity would rather forego the
embarrassment of nude pictures being
released that she would settle rather
than prosecute the crime this happens
all the time the shakedowns of people in
positions of of power certainly uh
public positions happen all the time and
I think that Matt Walsh was smart by the
way to say I was hacked because you know
what they were going to try and do I
think that Tucker Carlson saying hey
look this is what's going on it removes
a lot of those teeth but you just need
to know that that's what happens all the
time in Rumble basically being held
hostage by hey if you're too successful
we're going to keep ddosing attacking
you uh DDOS help me out denial of
service tactics where they overload
servers they hack in behind it's kind of
an umbrella term pointers are being
hacked they get that at a restaurant
yeah Bob Evans the early bird special
where you can go you can get a stack of
pancakes and hear the n-word Relentless
love around you really yeah Bob Evans
get the address only until 10 a.m though
then they outlaw the n-word yes that's
true well no it's just it's just set in
code ah well but they're too loud so
they don't say it in code they still
just say it by the way can I admonish
you really quickly can we get an
admonishment what happened yeah
Pat Robertson actually like pressed two
thousand oh my word do we have a video
or the picture I don't know if we have
an overlay or something hoodie what
nothing where are you guys going with
this one you don't have your microphone
anywhere near you who did you have the
picture have you done this before yeah
we have a picture here uh did Pat
Robertson leg press 2 000 pounds this is
an article written 2006 according to the
CBM website Robinson worked his way up
lifting a ton with the help I don't care
what some article says do we have a
picture of the old man breaking his hip
so we have this as well when he was 73
oh okay so 40 years ago okay here we go
ladies and gentlemen of this oh
extraordinary
this is you can see that yeah I can't
see a monstrous amount of weight on that
thing but you you measured the 2000 you
measured the 2000 pounds his Ranger
movies
I guarantee you that he did it he took
his Miracle Water and you know it worked
yeah but if you need that by the way leg
press is not a real lift okay if you can
lift 2 000 pounds I might as well lift
it with a forklift I'm the strongest man
in the world but he also himself
he had the opportunity God was listening
closely I know God hears us all don't
get me wrong here but God was listening
closely enough to Pat Robertson that he
used it on lifting 2 000 pounds yeah he
couldn't save the Lord help me leg
pressed two thousand pounds then he
parted my red cheeks
never mind
it's so funny I'm 98 it's still funny
come on all right you guys can comment
below this has been curious coincidences
laughs
[Music]
hey Nick let me ask you and also in all
serious yes you've done a lot of radio
for a long time have you ever seen
anyone better with a soundboard than
Yakuza absolutely who who
yeah with the sound board unbelievable
he's like the keyboard is yeah for the
monkeys yeah he's great I love it they
faked it I know that was my point you
know what's funny it's unbelievable oh I
didn't know sorry no I just told the
Gerald and ruined your joke I apologize
no no no no you didn't you know the
monkeys yeah Jimi Hendrix open for them
please tell me you made that up I
guarantee you I did not make that up
come on imagine this Pride swallowing
siege that must have been for Hendrix
killed himself
yeah
when he took acid he had flashbacks to
beat a Dolan's walking into the shower
uh Mike Nesmith Mickey dolans Mickey
dolans you know who's Peter uh Peter is
he was in there somehow there's some
Peter in there uh yeah they were all
Peter puffers am I right
what was Mike you know that I know you
know this guy smart and uh
Mike nesmet what was his mother known
for what Ned Smith well I don't know
what his mother was known for inventing
white out really yes oh that's racist
and I made it up
that's true and Mickey dolins that's how
I know my career was in a toy on a few
years everywhere I went I was following
him yeah really the weekend before you
ever been swapped out for Sean Hannity's
Freedom tour
just peek behind the curtain like oh
he's doing Nixon again okay
all right so uh before we go to a mug
Club here we're going to cover this
story uh there's now three gay men it's
a thrupple and this is important because
we're going to talk about adoption
remember hey it's just about gay people
getting married look behind you there's
a slippery slope hey gay people should
be able to adopt kids just like anyone
else well now they're actually
forbidding Christian couples
from adopting children in certain States
so let's start with this uh three gay
men it's a throuple as a new I mean it's
not a new term but I just don't like
using it uh they're looking to be the
second one in the United States ready to
adopt so she's apparently going to labor
Style
fake apparently because they put the
baby in velcro velcro and it's swaddled
oh wow
[Music]
ah
um that's terrific touching so hey uh
we're going to discuss this there's no
way we could discuss it on YouTube we
could on Rumble but of course if you're
not a member of mug Club there's another
full 45 minutes to hour of show where
Nick can let it rip there's nobody just
got 45 more seconds and you can go to
nickdip.com or is it Nick is it Nix
Apollo show.com or nickdip.com that's a
good question don't ask me it's both
the funniest stand-up comedian
as far as pure stand up it's like I say
if you watch if you want to learn how to
box you watch Joe Lewis you want to
learn how to actually do stand up
properly you watch Nick depalo and
people like Louis CK and Bill Burr will
tell you the same thing so it's not just
me saying it if you are watching on
Rumble right now click the button below
you just click that button you get to
continue watching for another 45 minutes
to an hour if you're on YouTube live
with credit.com YouTube thank you very
much but we despise you piss off
thank you